hey everyone i've got a cool
announcement and a brief message to
share with everyone today
i recently received this email from
youtube to inform me that i've been
accepted into youtube edu
youtube etu is a collection of the best
education channels on youtube spanning
primary school all the way up to
university and beyond
i'm in the primary and secondary
education category which currently has
sections for science
languages history and maths which is
where i feel
and wetube is at one of the very few
australian channels which is a bit sad
but it's also exciting to be at the
forefront of a relatively new trend
which is developing
really fast so i just wanted to share
this news with you that was the cool
announcement
now the brief message and today's the
last day of school for term three and
that means that utah's across the state
have finished all their classes for the
entirety of high school
and they just have a final few weeks
before they sit their actual hsc exams
now when i started this channel and
began to put up
videos online i knew that it was going
to be more than
just my class who was watching and yet
in the last few months i've just been
amazed and astonished and really
grateful how many people have been
viewing
and subscribing sending in questions and
sometimes even just writing to say thank
you it's really blown me away
that i'm really just doing my job and
i'm really glad that lots of people have
benefited from it
so i really hope that in these last few
weeks you don't lose focus
keep your eyes on the finish line don't
despair even when it can be very
discouraging just doing
practice question after practice
question all these exercises
the end is near and there's a great you
know
few months of holidays waiting for you
afterwards and i hope that the results
you get will take you wherever you want
to be
so i just want to wish everyone well um
all the people who are out there
whatever
um class or school or state or
country you're in good luck see you guys